[Music]
water is light especially for Farmland a
steady supply of water is crucial for
healthy crops and a Bountiful Harvest
while many rely on traditional
irrigation methods there's a natural and
sustainable solution rainwater
harvesting this age-old practice
involves capturing storing and using
rainwater transforming your Farmland
into a thriving ecosystem rainwater
harvesting offers a simple yet powerful
way to supplement your water needs it
reduces dependence on external sources
and empowers you to manage your water
resources effectively by embracing this
natural cycle we can create more
resilient and productive farmlands for a
sustainable future imagine a gentle rain
shower nourishing your crops
replenishing groundwater and
revitalizing your land rainwater
harvesting makes this Vision a reality
it's time to unlock the potential of
this valuable resource and cultivate a
brighter future for our farms and
communities
[Music]
rainwater harvesting at its core is
about working with nature it involves
collecting rainwater runoff from various
surfaces and directing it to storage
systems for later use this simple
concept has profound implications for
Farmland offering a sustainable way to
augment irrigation recharge groundwater
and enhance soil Health the key
principles of rainwater harvesting are
straightforward capture store and
utilize we capture rainwater from
rooftops roads open grounds and even the
fields themselves storage can be in
ponds tanks or underground reservoirs
depending on your needs and space
finally we utilize this harvested
rainwater for irrigation livestock and
other Farm activities by integrating
these principles into our farming
practices we can create a closed loop
system that minimizes water wastage and
maximizes resource utilization rainwater
harvesting is a journey of understanding
and working with the natural water cycle
ensuring a sustainable and prosperous
future for our
farmlands ponds are a time- tested
method of rainwater harvesting acting
like giant bowls that capture and store
rainfall they are versatile cost
effective and seamlessly integrate into
the landscape enhancing both the
functionality and Aesthetics of your
Farmland constructing a pond involves
Excavating an area to a suitable depth
and lining it with an impermeable layer
such as clay or a synthetic liner the
size and depth of the pond depend on
your specific water needs and the local
climate proper planning and design are
crucial to ensure efficient water
storage and prevent seepage ponds offer
numerous benefits for Farmland they
provide a readily available source of
water for irrigation especially during
dry spells the collected water can also
be used for livestock watering reducing
Reliance on groundwater or Municipal
supplies additionally ponds create
habitats for wildlife enhancing
biodiversity and promoting a healthy
ecosystem on your
farm recharging groundwater is critical
for long-term water security bore Wells
and open Wells direct rainwater back
into underground aquifers this process
prevents depletion and ensures a
sustainable groundwater Supply it raises
the water table making groundwater more
accessible for irrigation it also
improves water quality by diluting
[Music]
pollutants section five rooftops to
resources harvesting rain from above our
farm buildings offer an often overlooked
opportunity for rainwater harvesting
rooftops these large surfaces can
efficiently collect significant amounts
of rain water which can be channeled and
stored for various uses harvesting
rainwater from rooftops begins with a
properly designed roof sloped roofs with
gutters and downspouts effectively
collect and direct rainwater towards
storage tanks or other harvesting
systems the size and number of Tanks
depend on the roof area rainfall pattern
and intended water use rooftop rainwater
harvesting provides a readily available
source of highquality water it's ideal
for irrigating Gardens watering
livestock and even for domestic purposes
after proper filtration by utilizing
this readily available resource we
reduce our Reliance on other water
sources and contribute to a more
sustainable water
cycle section six guiding the flow
conveying water efficiently efficient
conveyance systems are the arteries of a
rainwater harvesting system ensuring
that collected water reaches its
destination with minimal loss properly
designed channels pipes and gutters
guide the flow preventing wastage and
maximizing the utilization of this
precious resource gravity plays a
crucial role in conveyance by
strategically sloping channels and pipes
we can utilize the natural force of
gravity to transport water from
collection points to storage or usage
areas this passive approach minimized
energy consumption and simplifies the
systems design when designing conveyance
systems it's essential to choose
appropriate materials durable and
non-corrosive materials like PVC pipes
or concrete channels ensure longevity
and prevent contamination of the
harvested water regular maintenance
including cleaning and debris removal
ensures the systems efficiency and
prolongs its
lifespan section s storing the Bounty
keeping rainwater fresh accessible
storage lies at the heart of any
rainwater harvesting system allowing us
to save water during times of Plenty for
use during periods of scarcity storage
tanks come in various sizes materials
and configurations each with its
advantages and considerations above
ground tanks often made of plastic or
galvanized steel are costeffective and
easy to install they are suitable for
storing smaller volumes of water ideal
for rooftop harvesting systems
underground tanks usually constructed
from concrete or Fiber glass offer
larger storage capacity and blend
seamlessly into the landscape choosing
the right storage tank involves
considering factors like storage
capacity budget aesthetic preferences
and local regulations proper tank
maintenance including regular cleaning
and inspection is crucial to prevent
contamination and ensure the longevity
of the storage
system Section 8 purifying the gift
ensuring safe and healthy water while
rain water is naturally pure it can pick
up contaminants as it flows over
rooftops surfaces and through conveyance
systems therefore purifying harvested
rainwater is essential to ensure it's
safe for irrigation livestock and even
domestic use after further treatment
simple filtration methods like slow sand
filters or gravel filters effectively
remove sediments debris and some
biological contaminants for higher water
quality more advanced treatment options
like UV disinfection or chlorination can
be employed to eliminate harmful
bacteria and viruses the level of
purification required depends on the
intended water use water for irrigation
might need basic filtration while water
for livestock or domestic use
necessitates more thorough treatment
regular testing of water quality helps
ensure that the chosen purification
method effectively meets your specific
needs section 9 success stories
rainwater harvesting in action across
the the globe farmers are embracing
rainwater harvesting transforming their
lands and livelihoods these success
stories highlight the tangible benefits
and Inspire others to adopt this
sustainable practice in India where
water scarcity is a pressing issue
countless Farmers have implemented
rainwater harvesting systems
significantly improving their crop
yields and reducing their Reliance on
erratic monsoons simple techniques like
building small earn dams and digging
Contour trenches have revitalized
parched lands and empowered communities
in the United States farmers are
increasingly integrating rainwater
harvesting into their operations from
rooftop systems on barns to large
Retention Ponds collecting runoff from
Fields these practices are conserving
water improving soil health and
enhancing the overall resilience of
their
[Music]
Farms section 10 reaping the rewards
benefits of rainwater harvesting the
benefits of rainwater harvesting extend
far beyond simply having more water
available it's an investment that yields
multiple returns positively impacting
the environment your Farm's productivity
and your bottom line one of the most
significant benefits is water
conservation by capturing and utilizing
rainwater we reduce our dependence on
groundwater and Municipal supplies
conserving these precious resources for
future Generations rainwater harvesting
also reduces storm water runoff
preventing erosion and flooding while
replenishing groundwater aquifers
furthermore rainwater is naturally soft
and free of harsh chemicals often found
in treated water this makes it ideal for
irrigation promoting healthy plant
growth and improving soil structure
using rainwater also reduces the demand
on energy intensive water treatment and
transportation systems lowering your
carbon
footprint embrace the rain a call to
action rainwater harvesting is more than
just a water management technique it's a
philosophy a way of life that respects
the natural water cycle every drop of
rain is a precious resource a gift we
can harness for a sustainable future the
Journey Begins With capturing that first
drop start small observe learn and
gradually expand your system every
effort contributes to water conservation
let's welcome rain as a valuable
resource transform our farmlands into
thriving ecosystems ensuring a water
secure future for Generations Let the
Rain Inspire sustainable agriculture